Bonjour.
Alors, je suis Daniel.
Daniel De Belyre.
Oui, alors... Pardon.
Je suis le maître des lieux.
Voilà... enfin...
Y a d'autres gens qui habitent là hein.
Mais sur papier c'est mon château quoi.
C'est à moi.
Venez, venez.
Alors voilà, donc ça c'est la salle du conseil.
Excusez un petit peu le bazar hein.
On a fait un méchoui avec des prisonniers.
Ah ! Notre emblème.
L'emblème, c'est la grenouille.
Notre devise est "d'un nénuphar à l'autre".
Mais !
On essaye d'en lancer une un petit peu plus accrocheuse.
Les mystère sont de mise.
Parce qu'on aimerait développer un côté un petit peu plus mystérieux.
Fort de notre grande expérience...
Nous pensons que nous sommes les dignes héritiers du trône de fer.
Un petit peu comme tout le monde...
Nous sommes les Frogz.
Pour assurer le fonctionnement de cette maison.
Je suis entouré de gens formidablement compétant et non rémunérés.
Comme maître Yorel, notre Mestre.
Avec qui "les mystères sont de mise".
Coucou !
Voici Clarisse, qui maintient la maison en ordre.
Et qui fait la petite popote.
C'est sexiste.
Qu'est-ce que c'est ?
Sexiste.
Des fois elle dit des mots mais...
Je comprends pas.
Être une femme lettrée, entourée de sauvages sans éducation c'est pas le plus dur.
Non, le vrai problème c'est plus les tentatives de viol pendant les repas.
Nous sommes les uniques fabricants d'un bon nombre de médecine que tout le royaume nous envie.
La plus célèbre en temps de guerre étant le lait de pavot.
Et voilà, encore un client de content.
Oh putain c'est des cailloux ! Chope-le !
Le trône de fer ?
Moi j'ai envie de vous dire "pourquoi pas".
On est une des maisons les plus anciennes du royaume.
Notre maître d'arme, c'est un descendant des chevaucheurs de dragons...
Du continent disparu.
Son ancêtre direct a vu les derniers dragons vivants.
Enfin c'est ce qu'il nous a dit.
J'aimerais bien qu'on arrête avec "c'est ce qu'il nous a dit".
Je suis un fils de dragon.
Juste, j'ai pas de papiers officiels.
Voilà.
Les Frogz peuvent aisément gérer le Royaume des neuf couronnes.
Y en a que 7 !
Hein ?
Y en a que 7 ?
Mais est-ce que vous en êtes sûr ?
Ouais, ouais, ouais.
Ouais, je suis sûr ouais.
Ok.
Bon, je me suis gouré, y en a que 7.
Mais on peut clairement les gérer.
Encore plus maintenant, parce que...
J'ai dit qu'il y en avait 9 et qu'on pouvait les gérer.
En fait y en a 7, c'est... facile.
On est un petit peu l'épicerie mystérieuse ou la pharmacie du Royaume.
Mais plus dans le sens vente de drogues et poisons.
Et on bosse pour tout le monde.
Les gens pour qui je travaille souhaitent tuer le roi Barat...
Hop hop hop ! Les mystères sont de mise.
C'est quoi ce bordel ?
C'est notre nouvelle devise en fait.
Oui non mais je m'en fou.
Paraît que vous avez du poison indétectable.
Exact, nous avons du poison indétectable.
Seulement ce que vous en ferez, les mystères sont de mise...
Mais j'en fait ce que je veux !
Grouille-toi, j'ai pas que ça à foutre !
Pour qu'une devise se répandent, faut la répéter.
Beaucoup.
Quelle masse corporelle a la personne ?
La personne qu'on veut donc empoisonner ?
Et avec qui les mystères sont de mise.
Tu le dis encore une fois et je t'égorge.
Ok, pas de problème.
Alors il est gros, il a de la couperose, il rigole très fort pour rien du tout...
Alcoolique, il est très gros, il a une barbe grisonnante...
Et il est souvent assis sur un trône de fer.
Soit il parlait de l'actuel régent du Royaume.
Soit... du Père Noël.
Le roi est mort.
Bon bah c'était pas le Père Noël.
C'est la guerre !
Les affaires reprennent !
Non mais c'est une sale nouvelle quand même.